i think one of the things that we as
bank of palin can offer and this is what
i'm using while i'm showing people
is the ability to impact the entire
industry
because when you are working with banker
pauline which is a huge sector in the
israeli financial
thing
everything that you do
has
the potential to impact the entire
industry
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance opus labs synergy global hello
at stanford leap birthright excel serona
partners and in media partnership with
ctec
welcome everyone to 20 minute leaders
meet ronnie
vice president of information technology
bank
ronen is an entrepreneur and information
technologies expert combining practical
and theoretical knowledge in advanced
technologies with proven experience in
leading complicated projects in
innovative technologies
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
so much for joining me today from the
bank of parliament offices right thank
you for having me i'm quite excited to
be part of this podcast
thank you very much ronan um you know
i've been meeting a lot of you know
people at vp positions and product and i
t and and and engineering et cetera and
a variety of startups but not yet from a
bank and so it's going to be an
interesting journey with you in these
next 20 minutes to sort of uncover what
what does leadership and innovation look
like within a an institution such as a
bank not just a bank but i believe
israel's largest bank bank police and
and you know innovation is happening all
around us you know we're seeing what's
happening to the financial industry
everywhere and you as vice president of
information technology i'm sure that you
reading the headlines you have to get
the wheels moving and and be able to
come up with some interesting decisions
as to what's happening so
tell me a little bit about yourself and
and let's dig deep into into what do you
do
okay so
first of all let me maybe introduce
myself
with more than just one sentence i'm uh
i'm 48 years old i mean with the bank
for the last seven years but before it
came from two startups um
which
which was quite an experience to be
honest one of them is still
running and kicking and then waiting for
the day that it will
bounce and be a unicorn and before that
there was many years in the army in the
different information technology units
in in the idf from amram
and stuff like that so i'm
bringing a vast experience in i.t and
also
what's unique maybe that i'm also
bringing experience in
in building something from scratch like
taking an idea and making the products
out of it um
i also have a phd in information
technology which gives me also the
academic side and maybe academic
understanding regarding the things that
we are doing
and in the bank we are basically i think
let's call it the software house of all
the different products about the
different services you can find in the
different channels of banker pauline
managing your account the ability to
take credit the ability to buy and sell
stocks everything is being developed
inside bank of berlin of course with
partnerships all across the industry but
we are the software house of the
software company of bank appointment
producing those
products
every day there is a new product or a
new service that is being introduced to
the world from our division
so if you're looking at the headlines
that that we're seeing today you know we
can't be
you know we can't ignore what we're
seeing we can't ignore the trends and
there's a lot of confusion around what's
happening what what does the person in
your position do
as you wake up in the morning maybe your
kids even send you on whatsapp this new
article from techcrunch talking about
the new nft crypto mambo jumbo that's
happening how do you make sense of it
all and come to make a decision about
this new world
first of all it's not mumbo jumbo the
crypto thing maybe we should
talk about it a little bit in a few
minutes there you go
not number jumbo at all it's an amazing
technology with amazing things that we
can do especially in the financial
sector but
let's keep it for for later on um we're
trying to see all the time that
that we are bringing the relevant
services at the right place to our
customers one of the things that we are
trying to see is the customer in the
center because today there is there is a
i think
everybody can say there is a competition
on the on the customer because
everything is a click away like if a few
years ago you wanted to consume
any kind of banking services or any kind
of financial services you had to go to
the bank today
the bank is with you everywhere and it's
not only the bank it's also the
competition like google apple everything
that we can read on the papers that
google and apple are trying to give some
kind of financial services to the
customers and to the israeli customers
as well so the competition is very very
strong
and we're trying to keep with the
competition that means we're trying to
give
a simple
um advanced services to our customers
let me maybe show one example it's the
beat application for example that many
people don't understand or don't
correlate it to bank of palin it's a
service from bank appointment that
allows any kind of person to transfer
money money quite easily to a different
person
uh via few clicks in the mobile app and
this is what we're trying to do we're
trying to align our our financial
capabilities to a simple
uh experience that can meet any kind of
customer
any place that means
if you want to consume financial
services today you can do it anytime
everywhere from your mobile device from
starting and opening an account like
using the open application of bank
appoint that allows you to open account
in seven minutes
and ending in advanced
services related to stock exchange stock
market exchange
any kind of credit issues loans deposit
everything can be done quite easily
today from any kind of channel in your
spare time in the evening in the morning
so this kind of let's say experience
must master aligns us or must
um make us think all the time how we can
improve and make our services more
relevant to keep up with the competition
and to bring the best service we can
find to our customers because as you
stated manchester poland is one is the
largest bank in israel we are also
100 years old
so we must we must always move on and
modernize our services
incredible and so if we're looking
specifically at crypto in this regard as
this new technology that is enabling
quick fast movement fast-paced changes a
lot of autonomy and independence to the
customers how does a bank
and specifically vp of i.t look at this
technology and make sense of how do we
now guide the strategy with this new
shift in consumer behavior
so it's an amazing question because the
entire financial industry is trying to
see what is let's say the best way to
align the
traditional banking with this kind of
new banking because i'm calling it a new
banking because the basic idea behind it
that there is no bank in the middle like
the banking industry can um
be let's say
accomplished by
no mediator in the middle so right it's
it's a banking with no bank um
but one of the things that we see that
eventually there is some kind of a trust
that must be aligned with your
capabilities or with your
let's say needs that means you need to
trust
the someone that you are doing banking
with
and
as long as
as long as we as a bank can provide this
service that means we can be part of
this new ecosystem of decentralized
finance and give the trust element that
is very very
let's say essential in order to keep the
financial system working this is where i
see the bank appalling coming into the
picture that means or any kind of bank
comes into the picture that means our
ability to bring our credit and to bring
our um
experience and knowledge and technology
and professionalism into this new kind
of banking services driven by the crypto
world that means our ability to be a
part
in this new distributed wave new big
banking system which means that we can
be one of the providers of those
services in this ecosystem it's not
replacing the bank it's just giving the
bank a new platform to give its services
in a different way so this is where we
are today we are trying to see what is
the best way best way for us like as i
stated the entire financial system
that we can cooperate with this new kind
of banking new this decentralized
way of working in order to give the
credibility in basically that
any kind of consumer looks for one is
trying to do any kind of a financial
service
so if we're looking at innovation within
a financial institution like a bank
right i mean big part of your job is you
know both innovating but then
facilitating the innovation as it moves
forward and and executing on that
innovation well what are the challenges
of that i mean you're i mean it's it's
you know it's a weird dissonance that
you're both living in in one of the most
in one of the fastest changing
industries ever yet you know
historically financial institutions are
also more complicated by nature where
innovation tends to take a little bit
longer to take place
so again you are right um
this is one of the main obstacles that
we as a let's say a large organization
are dealing with but
if you are trying to see
our capability to prod to produce new
products and our capability to be let's
say competitive to
other big vendors like like as i stated
the
googles like and the apples and the
facebooks
we are to be honest we're trying um
to embrace
this new way of working in order to
produce services to produce products
much faster so that means that in the
last three years for example
we've embraced the new ways of working
from
the the industry that means we have we
have embraced automation wherever we can
we are talking about devops we are
talking about continuous integration
continuous delivery those are curses in
a technology
language that means we have the ability
to move much faster
like the
big guys and we're also embracing ways
of works that coming from the fintech
startup scene that means we are
embracing agile methodologically of
working that means we are working in
springs of two weeks every two weeks
we're releasing new products
we are working with something that calls
tribes that means we are transforming
the way we're working we're not talking
about pro projects anymore we're talking
about
small quantities of new services that we
as i stated
release all the time with the business
side
working with us with high alignment to
the business side in order for us to
answer the business need so we are
talking about embracing new technology
that comes from the big companies and
embracing new ways of working that comes
from the startups so together we are
trying to move faster and to be honest
we are quite succeeding in this manner
we have
um for example in the last year while
all the issue of the coving 19 was going
on
we have managed to
release
new new services to
answer the demands for digital services
for the customer that staying at home in
almost a pace of once a week so this is
something that is very very unique just
and as a proof today
i think huge revolution that we as a
bank are moving that the technology is
in a way
serving the customer much better we are
earnesting a technology to serve our
customers much better but in a way the
technology also allows us in some cases
to define the business services
we see the technology and the innovation
is one of the key elements that allows
us to ought to
offer our customer new services new ways
of doing business new ways of working
and to be honest it's quite amazing
because the entire industry is going
that some kind of evolution that means
we are
all together embracing the digital
services that as i stated in the
beginning you can you can do everything
today from home you don't have to come
to the bank anymore that means you don't
have to come to the branches for example
you can do everything by the online
how do you as a leader you know think
through talent in a place like like a
bunker boiling because you know the
market is crazy every day we see new
headlines and you know it's it's
brand is such a has such a big part of
it and how do you think through talent
and engaging your current employees and
and getting new engineers to join the
team as you build your digital efforts
so to be honest we are suffering like
the entire industry in the israeli
economy now that there is a huge
competition on talents uh
we see
we see it everywhere you just need to
open the any kind of newspaper to see
that the market is hectic
good people are
being i i think
being a i don't want to use a huge words
but that they're being uh
hunted to be honest by head hunters all
the time and and it's a struggle but
i think one of the things that we as
bank of palin can offer and this is what
i'm using while i'm showing people
is the ability to impact the entire
industry
because when you are working with banker
polling which is a huge sector in the
israeli financial
scene
everything that you do
has
the potential to impact the entire
industry we are um
we are embracing as i stated in the the
cutting and even in some cases bleeding
edge technologies in in the financial
market we are using those technologies
to show the people that they have the
ability here to use the best
technologies and on the other hand
we are giving them
the
let's say the potential to impact the
entire industry because for example i
don't know if you know but
it's it's uh an amazing embracement of
the entire israeli community regarding
beat every person is using b today
as a way of p2p
money transfer between people and it's
now also becoming the best way to pay in
in
in commercial places like mcdonald's
dominoes and stuff like that so
i'm telling people for example if you
come you
will have the ability to create the next
beat the next business applications the
next financial application and in some
cases
it's not just appealing to people but
they're also willing to come in order to
gain the understanding of the financial
world to gain ideas regarding maybe new
fintech companies
and and it's part of our offering let's
come to us learn regarding the financial
market in israel have the ability to
impact use the best technologies you can
find
use the best ideas and new ways of
working
so we're trying to
to use those
advantages in order to appeal people to
come and to work with us and in most
cases we quite succeed to be honest
and and now honey you've really you know
dipped your toes everywhere you've you
know in academia as a phd in the
military and startups and now at a
financial institution at bangkok
why do you do what you do so you've seen
it you you've experienced the whole
spectrum of the things that you that you
could be doing yet you choose to now be
at this position in bangkok why
why it's a good enough question i think
i think the answer relies in my last
answer
the ability to impact
i truly understand and truly believe in
it
everything i do here
as a financial institute that produce
business products produce business
services that can basically touch
um
many if not all of the israeli citizens
it's it's an enormous
power like the the idea of that i can be
part of
the digital transformation and the new
business services being uh produced for
example in the crypto world to be
produced to the entire israeli economy
and maybe even more
it's something that for me personally
quite appeals
um
it's not an issue to be honest of mine
it's not an issue of uh
it's just the idea that what i what i'm
doing here is the
basically the potential to touch
to touch mikhail to touch one end to
touch my three girls at home to touch
everybody in the israeli society
it's quite appealing to be honest
and if you had to
distill from
you know
it's a two-sided question both you know
the the most joyous moment or the most
joyous joystick type of experience that
that you go through in your day-to-day
but also the most challenging one of
your role so so what is most joyous but
also the most challenging
managing people with no doubt
this is like the main issue this is most
of my time because uh
in one way those are the best people you
can find today those are the the people
that in a way um
redefining the entire financial market
they are using technology to redefine
products we define services to redefine
the way we're doing business
on the other end
it's quite a task managing them
they're very knowledgeable
and
they don't
take for an answer
and they want to
believe that what they're doing
can truly benefit the customers in the
israeli society so
in one way you need to give them the uh
the let's say the
the
um
place to work and to bring their
innovation on the other hand you have to
manage them to align
to the business needs because eventually
we're also serving the business units
here the the retail unit the commercial
unit
so it's quite a struggle to manage those
kinds of people and again you have to
understand that they've alternative all
the time they need to choose to come to
work with me
every day
from from start like every day again and
again they have to choose to come to
work with us with bank appointment it's
it's quite an issue to manage this kind
of
dilemma every day
i love the perspective of them having to
choose day in and day out that they're
going to continue choosing making this
choice and and going back circling back
to the beginning of the conversation
about the way that you're approaching
the the new innovative technologies and
the way that you're putting the customer
first i think that really you know is a
is a theme in this conversation that you
you're talking about impact in the sense
of the fact that the products you're
building at the end are touching you
know really every person you know it
starts from the financial industry but
the ripple effect to our daily lives is
is incredible and and that is a
motivator i think is is really really
amazing and one and i really want to
thank you for spending these 20 minutes
with me i learned a lot and i
gained a lot of inspiration myself and i
think this is this it was insightful to
hear from somebody
in in an organization that is often can
be perceived as large and complicated
but at the end 20 minutes talking
directly about you know consumer
experience and innovation it was very
very refreshing so thank you very much
everyone
last remark that keep in mind that
eventually behind any organization there
is a people that are doing the
organization there is there on end there
is a miri there is an ad there is an
acting there are people are doing the
this organization and
it's all about people eventually all the
time
beautiful ronan
stay safe and stay healthy thank you
you